[Music]
on this wednesday night
getting olympic gold canada's andre
degrasse
dashes to the top of the podium i knew
he would take it
the records he just shattered
accusations of racism
after police shot and killed a black man
in quebec instead of getting help
he got three bullets demanding justice
for jean renee junior olivier
skepticism over ontario's plan to keep
covet out of classrooms
and mounting pressure to mandate shots
for healthcare workers
plus a nuttier version of the olympics
uk up first here he comes
the competition where things can get
[Music]
squirrely
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
bara nasser good evening to you and
thank you for joining us
we begin tonight with that stunning
golden moment
for canadian sprinter andre de grasse
now for years he's been one of the best
in the world
but now he's officially on top after
winning gold in the men's 200 meters in
tokyo
de grasse crossed the finish line in a
blistering 19 19.62 seconds now that is
both
a personal best and a new canadian
record
the 26 year old from markham ontario is
no stranger to the podium he's now won
five olympic medals
but this is his first gold and
he is the first canadian in nearly a
hundred years
to win the 200 meters event crystal
gomencing has tonight's top story on the
race
and the reaction here comes the grass
accelerating in less than 20 seconds
andre degrasse
rewrote canadian track and field history
accomplishing
something that no man has done since
1928
and to do it he had to overcome a slow
start
against a loaded field of american
sprinting stars
victory was anything but a short his
incredible finishing push
overwhelmed the field resulting in a
glorious
hard-fought victory i knew it was gonna
be tight and uh
it was tight so uh definitely uh
thankful and appreciative that uh
you know i got the gold that laugh and
smile
hallmarks of the canadian star a humble
and hard-working guy who originally
wanted to play
basketball oh i'm wearing the wrong
color
degrasse's mom may not be wearing red
but she is
definitely proud this strength he has at
the end of his race
like i knew i knew he would take it he
was really hungry for this he really
he really wanted to bring home this
olympic gold medal
for for canada for himself for the
family and everybody
degrasse now has five olympic medals but
this
is his first gold it's god-given man
it's just
it's a god-given gift that he was born
with i've been like i said i've been in
the game a long time and
what andre was able to accomplish in you
know the first year of
formal training or formal coaching it
just doesn't happen
tony sharpe saw greatness in degrasse
back when he was just 17
and enrolled him in a development
program running fast is great but
andre brings the full picture to the
table so i gotta tell you you know
again i'll just go back he's a real role
model and
people love andrea because he's just a
good
person the accolades are pouring in for
the 26 year old but he is not done
yet he will be taking part in the four
by 100 relay
giving him yet another shot to flash
that big smile
chuckle and hold up the maple leaf
crystal gomanson global news london
canada is now in 15th place in the
overall metal count with 15 medals
four gold four silver and seven bronze
and canada still has several more metal
chances before the games wrap up this
weekend
the canadians will be pushing for that
podium spot in the men's 4 by 100 meter
relay this friday
and there's also the men's decathlon
after the first five events
two canadians are in metal position
damien warner is in first
and pierce lepage is in third
and tomorrow the canadian women's soccer
team goes for gold against
sweden the match is scheduled for 10 pm
eastern time tomorrow which is 11 a.m
friday in tokyo but
both the canadians and the swedes want
the start time pushed back
to later in the day and that's because
of extreme heat
the forecast is calling for late morning
temperatures that could feel like the
low 40s
the ioc has not yet responded to the
request
there's a new development in the saga of
the olympic sprinter from belarus who
said she'd
feared returning to her home country
christina timonovskaya has touched down
in poland
the 24 year old sought refuge at the
polish embassy in tokyo earlier this
week
after she said team officials tried to
send her home early
because she criticized team coaches
temenovskaya said she'd be punished by
belarus's authoritarian government
if she returned home and she feared for
her safety
she and her husband were granted
humanitarian visas by poland
and in japan the pandemic threatens to
overshadow the excitement of the games
cases are rising at such a rapid rate
the government made a controversial
decision to
limit hospitalizations the prime
minister says
only people who are suffering serious
symptoms should be hospitalized
while people with moderate symptoms
should isolate at home
and on tuesday the head of the japan
medical association
urged the government to declare a
nationwide state of emergency
japan reported 14 000 new cases in the
past
24 hours more than 4 100 of them are in
tokyo
and 90 percent of the new cases in the
capital
are the delta variant here in canada the
delta variant is expected to fuel a rise
in cases
as we head into the fall that has
provincial governments assessing how
they'll handle
a return to in-person learning the
ontario government says it won't
make covet-19 vaccines mandatory unlike
measles and the tetanus shots but
students will be required to wear masks
indoors
and the province plans to spend millions
on air filters
shawn o'shea looks at whether that'll be
enough to reduce the risk of covid19
in classrooms 34 days to the start of
school again in ontario
it's an unsettling time for this mother
whose two children
contracted covet 19 in the last year i
think my kids are
appropriately terrified to get it again
but christine baker is resigned to
reality at some point you've got to
start doing your stuff again
and going to school is one of those
things ontario's plan is to get students
back in class
it includes mandatory mass use indoors
and physical distancing as much as
possible
and now 25 million dollars to be spent
on air filters
all occupied learning environments
including classrooms
without mechanical ventilation will now
have a standalone hepa filter
placed within it air filtration is
important says this
engineering professor who specializes in
air quality
professor jeffrey siegel says 25 million
dollars is better than nothing
although he says some schools especially
older ones
need far more retrofitting than others
to be safe we should be targeting
the resources that are available to
where they're going to have the most
benefit there is no panacea
that's hvac related it's really just a
matter of what is the right
solution in the context of the building
that you're dealing with in every
building will be different
just as every province is different
british columbia hasn't decided on mask
wearing for schools
and it won't insist students stick to
their own cohorts
alberta's already lifted all covet
restrictions and masks
won't be required at school still
critics of ontario's back-to-school
plans aren't impressed
mr ford said you know we're releasing
the best plan in the world
for schools and we actually ended up
with classrooms closed
for more time than any other
jurisdiction and this recommendation
open windows to help keep these
classrooms and learning environments as
safe as humanly possible
for parents looking ahead after the last
exhausting school year
the hope that this one will be easier i
mean all we can do is try it
and go we have to move forward charles
shea global news toronto
two major health groups are calling for
vaccinations to be mandatory for all
health care workers
the canadian medical association and the
canadian nurses association
say the shots are key to helping keep
the public safe
civil organizations in ontario have
called for mandatory vaccines also
in that province more than 596 000
health care workers have received at
least one dose
and more than 577 000 they're second
but as abigail beeman reports there are
questions around whether it's
legal to make it mandatory
if we are going to make good
for this winter we better get on get on
with it now
the registered nurses association of
ontario was the first to call for
mandatory vaccinations for healthcare
workers last month
now as more organizations join the push
across the country
its ceo is not pleased ontario's premier
won't heed it i'm disappointed that the
province doesn't have the guts
so far no province has made vaccination
mandatory tuesday the canadian medical
association and the canadian
nurses association put out a joint call
we work in an industry that everyone
that needs us
is potentially susceptible to picking
something up
and and having poor outcomes i think
it's always challenging
for governments to make these decisions
but i think our job as leaders in
healthcare is to sometimes make
difficult decisions and lead with
science and i think the science is clear
unlike ontario and alberta bc hasn't
shut down the idea it's important to me
that we have all of this nailed down
before we go into the fall respiratory
season
as for whether individual employers can
act on their own
there actually is quite a bit of legal
basis to say
that employers if need be can require
vaccinations
we know some health care workers are
vaccine hesitant but there's a lack of
national data about just how many have
their shot
a lot of healthcare workers are
marginalized women so a lot of them have
questions on
pregnancy fertility and these are all
valid questions to have and all it
really takes is having this one-on-one
discussion
sabina vara miller has helped many with
questions like that decide to roll up
their sleeve
she says the reason some health care
workers haven't been vaccinated are
varied it's a complicated issue
whether we have these healthcare workers
who are working 100 hours per week and
just don't have the time to go get
vaccinated
or don't have sick time to go get
vaccinated or worried how are they going
to do their job if you know they have a
sore arm for instance
she believes the vaccination rate would
climb if there was more education
and paid sick days post shot abigail
beeman global news
ottawa the world health organization is
calling for a moratorium on booster
shots until at least the end of
september
to help ensure enough doses are
available for
low-income countries the who says it
wants to see
10 percent of people in every country
vaccinated first
it also says the science is unproven
about whether giving booster shots to
people
who already have two doses is effective
israel france and germany are among the
countries already administering boosters
canada says it's planning for the
possibility and it's watching the
science carefully
there are now more than 200 million
cases of the virus globally
in china 12 million people in wuhan are
being tested
after the city detected its first
domestic cases
of the delta variant wuhan where kova 19
first emerged in late 2019
had reported no local infections since
may 2020.
on monday the city recorded three and in
beijing
part of an industrial and technology
zone was sealed off to help contain
a growing outbreak
heartbreak outrage and accusations of
racism in quebec
coming up the calls for justice for a
black man killed by police
plus the wildfires devouring parts of
greece
[Music]
quebec is launching a new police unit
following a sharp rise in shootings and
gang-related violence
we will be creating a targeted team an
integrated team nikit
that will be a hundred percent
concentrated on fighting against
violence
linked to guns and gangs montreal
and provincial police are going to work
together to target gun violence in
quebec's largest city
on monday evening three people were
killed in a drive-by shooting at an
apartment building
those deaths bring the number of
homicides in montreal to 16
so far this year there is growing anger
over the actions of police
in a suburb of montreal after officers
fatally shot a 37-year-old black man
it happened in rapontini on sunday
morning the victim's mother said she
called police for help
and she hoped officers would take her
son who was in distress in experiencing
a mental health crisis to hospital
the family is demanding justice blaming
racism
inside the city's police force for the
deadly response
instead of getting help he got three
bullets
as a mother myself i have three kids i
feel
that we are not safe we want answers
we want answers police say the man was
armed and threatened officers we go now
to olivia o'malley she's in rapunzel
olivia tell us about the vigil and
protest happening behind you
pharah the sit-in just started just a
few minutes ago here
outside reponting city hall right behind
me
his fam john kennedy olivier's family
and friends have taken to the mic
calling for the end of systemic racism
to take it down here
and dozens of attendees are wearing
white shirts on the shirt it does say
justice for junior and across the front
there are three
bullet holes rapontani police killed the
37 year old on sunday morning his
grieving mother called the police for
help
but instead she says they shot her son
she says olivier said he was seeing
people who wanted to hurt him
according to quebec's independent
investigations office mandated to
investigate
when officers arrived olivier was
disoriented and holding a knife
police claim they tried to negotiate him
with him but
he fled on foot they allegedly tried to
use pepper spray to subdue him but were
unsuccessful
his family says he was shot three times
as for the three bullet holes on the
shirts and want answers
the protesters here now are actually
taking a knee
and they all say they want justice a lot
of the members of the black community in
reponting
say they don't feel safe take a listen
to what his cousin had to say earlier
everybody to feel that our skin color
is not a problem we want to be treated
like white people because we feel that
white people have more privilege than us
protesters here have taken a knee and
are having a moment of silence
they say they won't rest until things
change here in ripontoni back to you
farah
another mental health call ending in
tragedy olivia o'malley and rapunzelny
quebec
thank you afghans left behind ahead
what's being done to help those who
helped our troops during the war in
afghanistan
you're watching global national
[Music]
thousands of people took to the streets
of beirut to mark the one-year
anniversary of that deadly port
explosion that devastated the city
protesters are calling for senior
officials to be held accountable
more than 200 people were killed in that
blast it happened after a fire
broke out igniting a huge quantity of
ammonium nitrate stored
unsafely for years it was one of the
largest non-nuclear explosions
in history so far an investigation has
failed to determine
who is responsible the first round of
afghan refugees who gave critical
support to canadian troops in the war on
terror are now
in canada as they start their new life
here
some of their loved ones are still in
afghanistan where they face danger from
the taliban which is gaining ground
against government forces
redmond shannon reports on the race to
help refugees their families
and the surprise reunion between one
veteran and an afghan helper
the aftermath of a taliban attack that
reached a little closer to the heart of
afghanistan's government
the bomb targeting the defense
minister's house injured
three people bismillah
muhammadi was not home at the time of
the attack but a four-hour
gun battle afterwards killed eight
civilians
another kabul bomb wednesday injured two
more
reflecting a recent spike in innocent
victims across the country
as fighting intensifies taliban ground
offensive and afghan national army
airstrikes
are causing the most harm and added it
is deeply concerned about
indiscriminate shooting and damage to
health facilities and civilian homes
afghanistan's president ashraf ghani
says the sudden withdrawal of u.s
troops to be completed this month is
partly to blame for the violence
the taliban targeting anyone who may
have helped western troops
it's making gains around herat garga
and the former canadian base of kandahar
these afghans in canada say there is no
time to waste in saving those who
supported
canadian forces i knew you're dead
yeah i was there in 2006
and you were playing videos outside all
the time do you remember me
this week's ottawa protest led to a
chance reunion between atala muhammad
and veteran dustin seabrook his father
was assassinated by the taliban just for
hanging around
being polite to canadians seabrook and
other canadians used to call
feeder muhammad papay i can't say enough
about these guys and how much danger
there really is
it's unbelievable and it's the more the
more we wait
the window gets shut on these on all
these families
the first refugees have now landed in
canada with more to follow in the weeks
ahead
campaigners are still concerned that
siblings and parents
are not explicitly eligible ottawa only
says it's taking an inclusive approach
and will bring thousands to safety
redmond shannon global news
london a searing summer heat wave over
southern europe has sparked raging
forest fires
and emergencies in seven countries
people on the outskirts of athens have
been ordered to leave their homes with a
wildfire closing in
right now greece is grappling with one
of its hottest weeks
since 1987. scorching temperatures
climbed to 47 degrees on tuesday
extreme heat has also fueled massive
fires in turkey
at least eight people are dead and
thousands of locals and tourists are
fleeing
coastal resort towns at least three
people are dead and dozens hurt after
two passenger trains crashed into each
other in the czech republic
a high-speed train traveling from munich
to prague ran
a stop signal and then collided head-on
with a local commuter train
the drivers of both trains were killed
along with the passenger
eight people were sent to hospital about
50 others
suffered minor injuries the czech
transportation minister says human error
was likely the cause
up next the squirrel summer games how
one man brought
the olympics to his own backyard
welcome squirrel sports fans to the
final
of the squirrel olympics the leptathlon
athletes in tokyo are not the only ones
going for gold right now
a british man created olympic themed
obstacle courses
in his backyard for squirrels which
should be an easy start for these
contestants it's the triple and long
jumps
there are four complex courses that
challenge the creature's agility
balance and strength decides to play it
safe
only the rings to go the man behind the
pun filled commentary is steve barley
it took him three months to build and
encourage his furry friends to compete
on camera he's done it he's got the gold
medal for portugal
in the end portugal came out on top but
the real winners
may be all of us
watch out andre de grasse and that is
global national for this wednesday i'm
farah nasser thank you so much for
spending part of your evening with us
tonight's your canada is gull lake in
alberta we love seeing your canada so
please email us your pictures
at viewers globalnational.com until
tomorrow
take care of yourselves and each other